j'ai bien rumeurs sur les chroniqueurs
arrive à jouer on va essayer de trouver
voilà à qui correspond les rumeurs par
exemple il ya quelqu'un en qui a dû
démentir une rumeur on a dit qu'elle
était qu'il était décédé qui la malice
et d isabelle non non non mais ça aurait
pu on l'a dit aussi mais on vous en êtes
où vous d'ailleurs c'est une fille et
d'une fille ouais on a dit qu'elle était
décédée
valérie sebag bravo ariès et ben allez
les gars on a dit vous étiez décennies
oui on a dit que j'étais décédé en fait
c'était parti d'un site parodique qui
dit alors qu'il courait produit un peu
les unes des balades et voici gala et
autres et du coup derrière les gens
n'ont pas compris que ces parodies away
prix l'info notamment sur twitter et
j'ai marqué en tout cas au niveau de la
tête et marque et hop us ben jours
je me réveille et je vois douze appels
en absence de ma mère en fait elle avait
reçu une alerte comme quoi j'étais
j'avais eu un accident de voiture
voilà dans la nuit et parce que c'est
des signes invente la mort déjà jugé pas
tari allait pleurer au téléphone
chamakh a salué même problème il y
disait que ce divorce et à chaque fois
c'était vrai alors évidemment c'est
toujours comme ça on a dit que j'étais
gay oui moi on a dit que j'étais gay tu
as dit benjamin c'était que c'est vrai
c'est vrai très longtemps en fait parce
que moi j'ai beaucoup d'amis gays et
j'allais souvent dans les boîtes de nuit
gay mais je m'amusais beaucoup avait là
bas donc on pensait que j'étais gay en
plus quand de lambeaux s'est installée
chez moi même semaine on s'est dit c'est
quand même c'est pas grave on a surtout
compris que c'était pas de rumeur mais
c'est quand même pas normal qu'ils
vivent avec son copain avec sa femme
sous le même toit sur l'amitié mais
amitié voilà j'avais autre femme sous le
même toit de laquelle la numéro deux
j'ai un doute - 3e et 3e la troisième
femme a donc juste avant la quatrième
fois oui il n'y avait pas la seconde
puisqu'elle n'existe pas hénart ce que
la seconde en dire qu'il n'y en a pas
derrière on entendu c'est un petit peu
de français ne fait pas de mal pour
cette émission
on a dit que j'avais fait de la
chirurgie esthétique et sachets
s'appelle anne on n'aura pas du tout oui
c'est une fille normale une fille assez
polis pas moi il n'y a pas cinquante ans
violée et séquestrée au quilit quilit
donc si vous aviez fait de la chirurgie
des titres wii et beaucoup de rumeurs
depuis le début de l'année et sur quoi
on a vu que vous avez offert faire court
en fait c'était avec le tenir ce
challenge qu'on a et agir challenger
oui et à ma voilà c'est avec cette photo
et je me suis fait mais à oui parce que
vous mais vous semblez assez froid et
ouais c'est la même personne c'est
exactement donc vous n'avez jamais rien
fait non jamais vous n'avez touchera
encore chez moi mais vous pouvez vous
pouvez refaire quelque chose
ouais j'avais pensé au nez
pétrole les refaire votre nez mais c'est
vrai qu'on a beaucoup parlé à sa
retraite complètement con alors j'avance
2000 bill foire et noëlla belfort
voilà non match aller alors je savais
pas parce que je parle mais les gens se
rendent pas compte en fait parce que
quand tu fais le plein et ça peut aussi
créer des complexes parce qu'au final à
mdr elle était moche avant elle a tout
refait faire il ce que les gens se
rendent pas compte qu au final quand on
lit des trucs comme ça et qu'il ya mille
commentaires comme ça ça peut blesser
des gens et ça peut aussi les inciter à
faire des choses dont on ne doit pas de
recette
avoir autant d'abonnés selon rien on ne
fait rien si on perd regardez ce qui est
arrivé à benjamin on a dit que je
couchais avec mon patron on l'a dit
c'est isabelle mais moi j'ai rien fait
refaire pour les nommer mais rapporte ok
alors c'était quoi cette histoire on a
dit vous couchez votre patronat à moi
j'ai ce qu'ajoute tepa maintenant
rassurez vous donc à l'âge où j'étais
comme estime comme je le dis tout le
temps sa cécité vsd péniblement pour
aller créer le duff inaugurait le tv mag
comme chef
oui donc c'est dur bien payé mais
j'étais h f
et mon ancien patron de vsd venu me voir
en disant maintenant faut vous reveniez
rpsd j'ai absolument besoin de vous ah
bon merci c'est gentil
donc j'ai laissé mon fauteuil j'ai
laissé tout l'argent que j'avais gagné
et je suis revenu avec un dock est
sollicitée revient et donc les gens dit
non mais elle est complètement con elle
si elle revient c'est que forcément elle
couche avec lui les gens qui n'y a
jamais rien eu également les jamais
revenu non on s'est toujours beaucoup
aimé fin j'espère qu'il me pousse à dire
oui c'est toujours beaucoup galoche sur
l'a12 à idées theroux d'abord jamais
couché avec un des boss aucun nom il y
en a beaucoup qui voulons demander
comment comment patrons demandent à la
note
on en est où tous les deux tu peux te
gêne je peux tout est fermé c'est
l'ancien y en a qui m'ont fait des
lettres non mais pourquoi j'ai gardé à
base de carte postale
ici il fait beau et j'aimerais beaucoup
te revoir à la rentrée isabelle alors
des trucs comme ça j'eus alain huc
mourir écrit des poèmes
non mais parce qu'on sait jamais quoi il
ya eu des gens qu'il faut se récrie de
moyenne ouais ils sont toujours de se
sentir seulement nos dernières nouvelles
ouais mais moi aussi d'ailleurs
ah oui non c'est fou ça regardez il ya
des gens vivants on a dit que je serai
ministre de nicolas au large colloque
doc à août on a des jeunes écoutant la
caméra qu'il arrive avec ses biens ses
docs ou pas c'est sur ce seul sait même
pas de quoi on a dit que tu allais être
c'est une rumeur non mais c'est vrai
qu'avec ses amis de nicolas n'ont jamais
s'il devait être ministre de l'énergie
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas lui c'est christine à huy est
ministre a lancé il ya eu un petit écho
qui est sorti de l'eau jdd y allons et
ça fait juste qu'elle a une de mende
journée au quotidien as
en jetant merde en disant que voilà le
daily telegraph en croyant que j'allais
alors c'était une rumeur dit oui ou
pastore n'ont alors après on m'a demandé
officiellement ma demande et après 10
min le noir car oui oui après on m'a
demandé trois fois après ça après tout
c'est oui 3 faudrait que tu as refusé la
piste trois fois ça doit être chiant
d'être ministre de l'outre-mer raison
parce que je trouvais que j'étais trop
jeune c'est à dire que je venais
d'arriver au csa premièrement je voulais
finir mon mandat
deuxièmement parce que une ultra marines
à l'outre-mer je trouvais ça pas top top
et puis troisième manche j'aime bien
dire non ses 8500 euros le poste de
ministre plus des notes de frais et
c'est ça le problème c'est qu'ils
acceptent les postes de mise pour les
1500 et pas pour la tomate en série aux
résonances et battue mais elle a très
utile tu peux être très utile
on dit souvent que j'utilise un
pseudonyme
on va rappeler les noms alors fait
rappeler les noms otages amis
non alors grinham et seraient
régulièrement les patients ne pense pas
parce que je suis pas médecin forcément
et que dit mohamed c'est un nom composé
que finalement j'ai voulu aussi par
francisé me cacher mes vraies origines
et un système sur twitter que j'en dis
dans mes assume un peu dit nous
l'apprenons bah ouais bah alors qu'elle
n'en pas ça bizarre tu viens pour
pouvoir opérer il arrive du yacht et le
mec de tpm plaît tu me touches pas tu es
chroniqueur c'est vrai non mais c'est
vrai mais moi je me vois c'est ce qui
m'est arrivé avec bétail mal essayé de
m'appeler chose c'était pareil pareil
bye bye et tout comme cette très belle
se soit envolé avec sa coiffure et je
trouve qu'ils disent est aujourd'hui
henri serait-ce que j'étais fait rien
non j'ai téléchargé des photos de
patoche sur google non hi hi hi pay
alors moi je dévoilerai pas ici mais
pourquoi vous avez été chez vous le
connaissez moi mais j'ai toujours
connais des jeunes visages qui vous leur
part parce que comme vous m'avez dit que
jimmy mohamed j'ai senti que vous
qualifiez jimmy mohamed et j'ai voulu
comparer jimmy mohamed et patoche et ça
c'est pas pareil
ces deux styles différents alors j'ai
trouvé une photo de lui et voilà j'ai
regardé toute la nuit et m'appeler nous
envoyer une photo non non je suis là
changement mais la faire rêver la
question c'est si tu avais été
célibataire
est-ce que tu aurait dragué jimmy ci lui
avait été scellé m oui oui mais non
parce que l'enterrement de fiction
n'avait rien d'un j'aime infiniment
jiminez comme un ami la russie avait
yoann érigé pas parce qu'on est avec un
avis qu'on a pas envie de savoir sa
molette
tendance à aimer les amap
non mais alors elle et 2000 ball est
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
finie arrêté j'ai sur moi je dis et je
suis je connais oui je suis sûr que
jimmy groupe et je vous aurais pu jouer
deux minutes mais oui arrêté je connais
la malléole mais bon les autres humeur
en fait je alors je voulais dire très
vite on a dit que j'étais en couple avec
une animatrice télé c'était mathieu de
l'embauché qui a absolument été fan de
moi c'était à m on faisait une fausse
paparazzade c'est pour ça on a dit que
j'étais d'été que j'étais la famille de
christophe rocancourt c'est vraiment bah
oui au hameau des milieux la plus belle
rigolade que j'avais fait j'étais parti
avec un pote il avait une voiture de
luxe ça alors écoutez les anecdotes de
raymond sont toujours que j'ai dit
j'avais 30 ans et m cayenne à une
voiture et le mec il est persuadé que
suit la famille dort encore je dis oui
c'est mon frère et il adore que je vais
essayer des voitures à vendre qui
viennent lui les acheter tenez regardez
là tout le week-end les mecs le fascine
voitures à 130 milles euros
j'ai gardé tout le week-end ouais
insertion d un autre concessionnaire ça
n'a pas marché parce que là on a dit que
je devais participer à danse avec les
stars c'est doc gynéco ouais ouais c'est
vrai en fait avec lui il savait il y
avait de la chance ils n'avaient pas
besoin de faire les ralentis
non non c'est vrai que moi j'ai cherché
tout l'amour et promis d une rumeur sur
moi ça tu as trouvé c'est vrai merci et
alors alors pourquoi je n'ai pas été
d'accord hier pour vous avez pas été un
jeu c'est pas en plus et payer hyper
cher ce sera moi je pense savoir
pourquoi c'est peut-être parce qu'il ya
une visite médicale avant un gamma gt
oui j'ai eu beau chercher je me trouvais
à vous on parle pas on danse c'est tout
mais on danserait nation mais on danse
agents c'est maintenant l'heure du
conseil de classe de jean michel mr le
maire de ses points sur benjamin tu sais
que c'est ma série non mais ils ont dit
que ces rumeurs